three girls five four and one oh my God
what is a typical day like yeah we'll
pray for me
well time to throw in one extra prayer
cause Derek Jeter just added one more
player to his at-home roster we have
some some interesting things coming yeah
the former Yankee keeping busy in his
retirement he secretly welcomed a son on
Friday with his wife Hannah Davis he's
one of two I'm one of three and get this
she predicted to E.T that three kids
might not be enough back in 2017. I
would say probably at least three
but I mean I I'm really getting ahead of
myself because I just need to like see
how I do the first time now fast forward
to Monday Derek takes to the gram to
announce bundle of joy number four No
Frills or photos for now but we do get a
name for the newborn kaius green Jeter
plus this message in the caption welcome
to the world little man I think for us
family has always been really important
we're uh extremely grounded and we have
very close friends and family around all
the time that kind of keep you in check
Derek in the Sports Illustrated swimsuit
model are also parents to River story
and Bella she's their oldest welcomed
into the world just one year after tying
the knot in 2016. I sort of assumed that
would be our next step after we got
married but um since I was a little girl
I mean I've always wanted to be a mom
and I always thought this would be such
a fun time and we've just we're in a
different point in our life lives now so
it's definitely it's going to be fun and
it's exciting and it's new so I can't
wait this also comes after Derek dish to
Jimmy Fallon about girl dad life in
February it's the greatest thing I've
ever experienced three girls five four
and one Controlled Chaos
the retired MLB star echoed
a new Instagram bio sleep deprived
father of four yeah we'll pray for me
the big question are the kids going to
walk in Mom and Dad's footsteps I think
sports for kids is unbelievable teach
you a lot of life lessons I just want
them to set their own goals and have it
nothing to do with us
um because I think it's not fair it is
it's a tough thing you know when when
you have like a mom that did this or a
dad that did this
um so I just hope that they don't have
the people don't have those expectations
for them and that they just do what they
love and what they're into
[Music]